let's just talk about not as you said
how to take certain guns away from all
people let's talk about how to keep all
guns away from certain people and those
being the people that we all agree
shouldn't have guns and unfortunately a
lot of the gun control that we have
right now primarily disarms the very
people who need protection the most if
my research convinces Me of anything
it's people who are most likely victims
of violent crime
overwhelmingly poor blacks who live in
high crime urban areas who are the ones
who benefit the most from having the
option to be able to go and protect
themselves the police are very important
but the police themselves understand
that they virtually always arrive on the
crime scene after the crimes committed
and having a gun turns out to be by far
the safest course of action
welcome to episode 122 of the Michaela
Peterson podcast
this is another opposing views episode
where I speak with two people separately
who have opposing views on contentious
subjects this is my favorite format of
episode and one I'll be focusing on more
in upcoming episodes I spoke with Dan
Gross and Dr John R Lott about gun
control in America in the first half I
talked to Dan Gross who did the stricter
gun control side of this debate after
his brother was very badly wounded in
the 1997 Empire State shooting gross
became a gun control activist
he's worked to raise awareness on gun
safety spearheading campaigns that teach
gun owners to mitigate risk gross is the
former president of the Brady campaign
to prevent gun violence and co-founded
the center for gun rights and
responsibility in the second half I
spoke with gun rights Advocate The
Economist and political commentator John
R Lott
he's worked for Yale the University of
Chicago and the U.S department of
justice under Trump he's the founder and
former president of the crime prevention
Research Center John Lott has published
op-eds in the Wall Street Journal the
New York Times the Los Angeles Times and
more please please remember to keep the
comments civil organizing these episodes
is very tricky and I really love doing
them I think they're so interesting so
let's keep things civil so that more
people will agree to come on next week's
episode is opposing views on bitcoin I
hope you enjoy this episode in this
format if you do please hit subscribe I
usually release episodes Tuesday and
Friday but I basically almost died last
week from a combination of strep and RSV
a virus I didn't know existed I'm barely
alive as it is you can probably hear it
in my voice kids are completely
overrated
enjoy your week
[Music]
Dan Gross welcome to my podcast
thank you Michaela
before we get started and I ask you a
bunch of questions can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do
yeah I mean what I uh what what I do
right now is a lot of things but the
reason that we're talking is because of
my kind of unique and extensive
experience working around guns in the
U.S I got involved with the issue
because my brother was shot in a
shooting that happened on observation
deck of the Empire State Building
actually in February of 1997 he was
shot in the head critically injured um
miraculously he's alive
um and so there's a lot to look at in
terms of that cup half full scenario but
for him obviously and for all of us who
love them and care about him it changed
the way we looked at what we do and and
our lives uh and in my case I at the
time I was a partner at a big Ad Agency
thought I was living my dream but uh
wound up realizing that there were
things that I could do applying my same
passion for marketing and communicating
to this issue of preventing others from
going through what my family's gone
through so I quit that job and
advertising started an organization that
was called Pax it became the center to
prevent youth violence it became the
biggest 501c3 nonprofit in the country
on on on guns
um and uh and then over time as that
organization grew built a relationship
with Jim and Sarah Brady who were
personally Heroes of mine and at one
point they called along with their board
and asked me if I would consider running
their organization down in DC which was
one of those deals where I said I'll
talk to them but it just doesn't make
sense I live in New York and they're in
DC and uh and but lo and behold they
have to talk to them it was just an
opportunity I couldn't turn down so I
ran the Brady campaign for six years
and and left a couple years ago
um for uh for a variety of reasons but a
big big part of it is I I was a little
bit burnt out focusing just on this
issue uh you know the worst thing that
ever happened to me and dealing with all
the Heartbreak um you know on a daily
basis that so many people go through so
uh yeah now to answer your question
finally um I do a lot of Consulting
um including on uh including still on
the on the gun issue and I've started an
organization called the center for gun
rights and responsibility to work with
the gun owning Community around the
common ground that have always been
convinced exists and right now
um people are listening to me more than
they they you know especially in the gun
Community
um than they did when I would they were
able to kind of caricaturize me as the
president of the Brady campaign so
that's what I'm doing a little more than
you bargain for right Michaela but uh
that's what I that's what I do that's
perfect that's perfect so I think we
should start off by you giving maybe a
an overview of what your stance on gun
control is and I know that's kind of a
large question but I mean is it some
people should own certain guns or just a
background about what you believe is
right for Americans yeah they're kind of
two first of all what I believe is right
for Americans is almost entirely
consistent with what most Americans
think is right for for most Americans
I'm not trying to prescribe anything I'm
just trying to find that common ground
that I was talking about and really I
think it Essence boils down to to two
things well one fundamental thing which
is you know we we all just want to be
safe and we get so caught up in this
polarizing political debate and
immediately you know pick a team pick a
tribe based on our political affiliation
and and we don't really realize all the
the common ground that that that is
there and Common Ground that'll
accomplish what we all want which is to
to make all of us safe at the end of the
day and there are two fundamental uh
aspects to that that I've always you
know made my quote career on this issue
um
career where I need more money I would
say an advertising this is a career
where the payoff is in creating some
positive change and there are two uh two
fundamental things
um one is let's just talk about not as
you said how to take certain guns away
from all people let's talk about how to
keep all guns away from certain people
and those being the people that we all
agree shouldn't have guns uh because
when we look at them you strip away all
the rhetoric and all the anger and and
and and and you know that's defying this
quote debate for so long you really
realize we all agree who probably
shouldn't be able to just Waltz into a
store and and buy a gun most gun stores
agree you know people it's just a it's
kind of an obvious thing when you look
at it that way and then the other half
of the equation is the responsibility
that gun owners need to take totally
compartmentalized from any political
conversation whatsoever about gun
control about the very real risks
associated with having a gun in the home
just like their real risks if you bring
a chainsaw into your home or a hammer
into your home and you know a piece a
piece of electronic equipment you want
to understand what those risks are and
then you want to do everything that you
can to mitigate those risks
unfortunately what's happened is that
because this issue is so immediately
defined as a as an emotional political
debate gun owners
too often tend to overlook that other
very important part of the conversation
let's talk about the suicide that
happens let's talk about the
unintentional shootings that that happen
but let's talk about him in a way that
gun owners can do reasonable things
without it all curtailing anything
politically their rights own a gun or
you know we've got to go into this with
a with a respect for the fact that
people who own guns
you know
my grandfather and father took me to
Yankee game so when I was a kid that's
what we did that's how we bonded you
know at this very moment their fathers
and grandfathers taking their kids
hunting and it's bi and we have to
respect that this is you know this is
not what this issue is about what I want
is when that father and grandfather take
their kid hunting that they're teaching
that child about firearm safety that
when they get into the home and they
have a teenager there that they're
careful to make sure that that teenager
isn't going to have unsupervised access
to that gun if you know that's what they
deem is is the safest thing to do so
those are the two fundamental things
politically it to me it's almost
entirely about just keeping guns out of
the hands of the people we all agree
shouldn't have them and then in terms of
education and awareness it's about just
starting a conversation about the very
real risks about a gun in the home and
without trying to take guns away or any
gun control or anything let's educate
people who bring guns into the home
about those risks and what they can do
to mitigate them
okay so that sounds pretty reasonable
thank you uh why why is it that you were
kind of caricatured and like vilified by
certain communities yeah
um I think it's because of how the kind
of knee-jerk reaction when it comes to
talking about this issue and you know
it's it's what is what does the media
want to show when it's you know to get
eyeballs it's people want to show a
debate
um and as a result what's happening is
you know I'm saying the same things that
I've always said uh but now people are
listening because I can't be
characterized as the president of the
Brady campaign because you know now I'm
I'm walking a different walk so I think
it's just a a symptom
um of of
unfortunately the way this issue has
been ingrained into the American
cultures and All or Nothing black and
white
um metaphorically
um issue rather than you know the
there's no incentive for people who run
organizations on both sides of the
issues by the way on both sides of the
issue they want to raise money
politicians want to raise their profile
they want to raise money so there's no
and this is this issue is not unique in
this regard it's a terrible example of
how you know it's a great example of how
terrible this issue can be
um but you know everybody wants to raise
money everybody wants to raise their
profiles and as a result there's really
no incentive for like a leading
organization on either side to really
genuinely respectfully put their arm
around gun owners and say like listen we
all want the same thing and that just
makes it easy and it kind of feeds on
itself and the result is like like
literally caricatures of me and you know
a leading magazine in the in the in the
Pro pro-gun Community with a megaphone
with fire spitting out of it and scared
children in the windows watching me
swing through the city like literally
caricatures but you know that that I can
deal with that's almost fun but it's the
uh what what happens as a result of that
which is
um it just contributes to this
um this this kind of idea that this is
just a political debate and and as a
result us not listening to each other
yeah well I'm I'm trying to figure out
how to bridge gaps in these contentious
issues so hopefully this helps
um so you talked about keeping all guns
from the wrong people so how would you
suggest judging people
um figuring out if they're the wrong
type of person yeah and let me start by
saying there's obviously no perfect way
to do that you and you get into some
genuine conversations about social
justice issues and you know other other
things that that that I care about
deeply but I think it's important to
start by realizing that right now those
people are defined
um you know there is the the Brady Bill
that became law
um defined and then there was an
amendment to it about domestic abusers
the Lautenberg Amendment defines those
people convicted uh convicted felons
um people who've been adjudicated
mentally ill people who have been and
convicted of domestic abuse I mean and
those background checks based on that
happen every day and they've saved
countless lives you know we're in the uh
in the in the hundreds of thousands of
of of I think it might be more than that
um of guns that have been sailed I
haven't looked at the figures lately of
sales that have been prevented to those
people in the prohibited categories
imagine how many lives that's it so
there's really people might want you to
think there's a there's a real struggle
and debate over how you would categorize
these people but the fact is they're
already you know why is the speed limit
55 instead of 57 you know at some point
it becomes an arbitrary conversation but
the important thing is that there is a
speed limit in place and it works and it
saves lives and so forth the problem is
that all the gun sales that happen in
our country every day that
um are outside of that background check
system so that background check system
only happens at federally licensed
firearm dealers and you know it's it's
there's one happening right now I
guarantee it where somebody is getting a
background check and and you know it'll
be decided whether they're in any of
those categories or not and they'll be
able to be able to get their gun the
problem is you know when you hear about
and I think this is language that isn't
helpful things like the Gun Show
loophole
you know what the gun show have you
heard of The Gun Show loophole no no the
Gun Show loophole is what people call
the fact people on the gun control side
call the fact that uh people can walk
into a quote gun show which Ambiguously
defined which is part part of the
problem and be
um and buy a gun without a background
check because it's uh because it's a gun
show and it's not a federally licensed
firearm dealer sometimes from federally
licensed firearm dealers and do it off
the books so that hurts the law-abiding
gun dealers because those people don't
have to charge taxes number not number
one but it really hurts all of our
Collective safety because if you're a
straw purchaser who wants to buy guns
and flood them into impacted communities
across the country you think you're
going to go to a federally licensed
firearm dealer to get those guns or do
you think you're going to go someplace
that does not require a background check
the reason why I think it's very
important to
um not just talk about it in terms of
the Gun Show loophole is that you know
first of all it's not true of all gun
shows but second of all it is true of
any place where guns are sold
commercially we're not talking about
exchanging with friends or and you know
there are conversations to be had in
terms of where that line is as well but
you know if I wanted to give a gun to my
daughter
um I don't think she should have to go
through a background check you know and
so where where is that where is that
line but there are people who are
clearly in engaged in the business of
buying and selling guns at all sorts of
venues online on websites that I don't
want to promote right now
at these gun shows but the problem is if
you turn them down at a gun show they'll
go across they'll go on to the parking
lot they'll go across the street into
the parking lot of the gas station so
there needs to be a law that and and
this is what I think could be the
biggest Improvement to the current
system there needs to be a law that
requires the commercial sale of guns how
we Define it we can talk about it
requires the commercial sale of guns to
have a background to have background
checks and that law would have a
tremendous impact and it would
um go a long way toward accomplishing
again what we all want which is just to
be safer
so you're saying that at the moment
there's no law that asks for background
checks for commercial the commercial
sale of guns no well commercial sales at
federally licensed firearm dealers to
get your federal firearm license you
have to conduct a background check and
those background checks are conducted
thousands of times every day
um the problem is
you're some sort of prohibited per your
uh convicted violent felon who's gotten
out of jail you go into a gun store you
try to buy a gun they you have to fill
out a form they do that background check
they say you know you're a convicted
violent felon you're not allowed to have
a gun you walk out of that store you
walk down the street in Most states
and many I'm not sure if it's most many
states and uh you go to a quote gun show
and that you that same person can buy a
gun from a table or somebody walking
around with with the same gun that they
wanted those people at the gun show I'm
saying the way to because some of those
are you know those grandfathers fathers
and their kids that I'm talking about
and hunting and let's go and look you
know I don't know if you went to like
shows like that car shows gun shows
whatever it is you know there's obvious
they're people who are genuinely into it
so I'm not saying that and if I just
sell one gun to one per person I'm not
even necessarily saying that that should
be the case but I'm saying if those
people go if people go to a gun show and
are selling you know some threshold
let's say you know more than five guns
every six months if they're taking
credit cards for their transactions if
they're advertising that is a commercial
sale and so those commercial sales have
to be made the same as the commercial
sale that would have gone down at the
um at the gun store had that fictional
person passed the background check
okay so why isn't that in place already
because people
misconstrue a lot of things and a lot of
the things we talked about
um people
misconstrue it as being a political
debate over gun rights people
um look at it you'll sometimes hear the
slippery slope argument well first you
want to do this and then you want to
take my rights away then you have
organizations again I believe on both
sides of the issue kind of feeding that
emotional Us Versus Them conversation
you know there's so much language that's
used like you know the gun nuts the you
know it's like don't do that these are
people who want you know what we want
and so
um as unfortunately as a result there's
this it's in it's become impossible to
change the political status quo because
it's so it's so entrenched so it's just
easy you know you can also say like why
did nothing happen after you know insert
horrific uh school shooting here you
know and that's a that's a question you
get a lot because
people have gotten good people who are
incentivized to maintain this as a
political debate have gotten good at
maintaining this as a political debate
and as a result the American public
isn't again getting the real story on
this issue and like look I'm you you've
done your homework and I'm talking to
you and you're like wait that's why
isn't that why isn't that the case
um and it it's it's so it is at the end
of the day so simple but that's
testimony to how just effing crazy this
issue is in terms of people you know
making it into this emotional political
debate
hmm interesting okay so what I've seen
in the news and what's been popularized
is the emotional debate where it's like
people shouldn't own guns period like
take everybody's guns away because guns
make the world more dangerous that's the
one side of the story and then the other
side is oh no guns make the world safer
because you can protect yourself from
the people who shouldn't have guns who
have guns so that's I guess the
politicized debate that's been going on
that's probably like the most
fundamental example of it yes and
the little secret is the reality is both
of those things are true
and so let's talk about it
yes
gun rights organizations that you know
aren't necessarily really concerned
about
the rights or certainly the well-being
of individual gun owners yes
um that got gun owning a gun presents a
risk
when you bring a gun into your house
let's talk about there is there are
scenarios where owning a gun is unsafe
why would you not want to educate people
about that scenario what you can do to
mitigate the danger that's not a gun
control conversation but that is that's
an education conversation but it's a
critically important conversation at the
same time gun control Community you know
a community that I helped to lead for a
number of years
um there is a right
to own guns you're not going to get
anywhere by trying to talk people out of
that right and trying to and and trying
to say nobody should own guns and you're
just gonna perpetuate that that polit
that political debate and even
there are scenarios where guns make you
safer
I mean I you know I have a place way out
in the sticks in the country and you
know I know a lot of people up there a
lot of friends that I have own guns and
I get it and you know you're that there
could be animals there could be
um there there could be an intruder it
may legitimately take a long time for
with no local police department for the
state troopers to get there you know is
there a scenario where you can
legitimately be safer to have a gun this
is blasphemy to a lot of the people from
the community or that I used to that I
used to lead is there a scenario where a
gun can make you safer yes
so let's have both of those it's not
cognitive dissonance let's have both of
those conversations at the same time
let's acknowledge there are real risks
let's talk about what we can do to
mitigate those risks and then let's
acknowledge that people who own guns
aren't all bad most of them aren't bad
most of them are good people who want
what we all want and our d and our
decent people so let's you know let's
acknowledge let's acknowledge that and
let's talk about the the fact that there
are people who derive real benefit and
value
um and fulfillment from owning guns and
let's then that sets up the opportunity
to have this conversation about you know
things like background checks on all gun
sales things like educating gun owners
about
um and it's not all gun sales by the way
but background checks things about
educating gun owners but right now like
you said what you see in the news is
just the people people don't dive as
deep as you're diving and don't look for
that Common Ground like you are so
there's like all right time to do a gun
control story queue up you know Dan
Gross and whoever the other person is
that you're gonna talk to and it just
winds up kind of fitting into this mold
that at the end of the day needs to be
broken in order to do something about
this issue
yes I agree
okay so so some other questions I had
just out of curiosity do states that
have stricter gun control
do they have less gun violence in
general you know so that's if you're
talking to somebody who goes and leans
on that argument chances are you're not
talking to somebody who either fully
appreciates this issue or is
worse using numbers to
[Music]
um kind of undermine
making some sort of genuine progress you
can't just look at state state by state
laws because you know it's a weakest
link thing if I'm in New York and New
Jersey has incredible that's it's not
true as good laws but if New Jersey has
incredibly weak laws I can just go right
over the Border There Are Places on the
board and there are all sorts of
examples of this there's a whole
thriving gun industry on the border of
California and Nevada because California
is strict well and so people who again
those people who might want to traffic
guns into impacted communities in
California they'll get in the car and
drive a few hours and go so you can't
say that you know states with tougher
gun laws have
um have
no difference in them amount of gun
violence and and present that as a
argument against anything that I just
said you know until this point
um with what I would view as positive
intentions
that was a totally reasonable response
thanks okay we've got a couple of other
questions to throw you away hit me I
feel like if you've you've had practice
though years and years of practice
okay
other countries
are there other countries that have as
many guns as the states but less crime
yeah
um
there's some debate about that I I will
say but you know because part of it is
and again it's a it's a little bit of a
red herring in terms of the conversation
which is why music what you're asking me
are never things that I use to justify
any of the positions that that we talked
about before I can tell you there are
states with some with significant
percentage of gun ownership like Israel
and you know where everybody
um up to uh you know has to spend two
years in the Army
um and uh Switzerland I understand has
but they
have way stricter
laws in terms of background checks and
all the kind of things that I'm
advocating
um you know and they're also more
respectful of the risks you know as I
understand in Israel your service weapon
you know is either has to be or
encouraged to be kept someplace outside
of outside of the home so again it's not
it's not the thing to focus on when
you're trying to make the case for any
of the uh for the two things that I'm
advocating which are keep guns out of
the wrong hands and educate gun owners
about the risks and yeah there's a whole
industry and it's part of that industry
of people who you will talk to
um hopefully is not as part of this
hopefully you'll talk to somebody who's
genuinely
um you know well-intentioned in terms of
trying to make our country safer but you
know there are a lot of people out there
who and and a good tests are the people
who make make those points because that
had in response to the things that I'm
advocating because let me just be clear
there is no connection between either of
those two things
and anything that I said prior to this
that I know will make us all safer
okay so the argument perhaps the
argument where they're like look at this
country there are more guns there and
it's safer they're not taking into
consideration the fact that these people
are are educated differently on guns
they're they're educated differently
they have different laws in terms of
who's able to get guns so ironically
some of those some of those countries
where that may rival the US I'm not sure
any place passes the U.S um but but you
know let's even say they do but at least
rival the US
um you know they they have much lower
rates of gun control gun violence
because they actually have the kind of
laws that that I'm talking about right
now in our country the problem is not
primarily the number of guns at this
point the problem is the hands that the
guns are getting into whether it's
unsupervised children somebody with
suicidal ideation
um or a straw purchaser who's funneling
guns into the impacted communities
that's those are the problems the
problem is not you know so it's again
that's used to kind of perpetuate this
political domain saying slippery slope
they just want to take all your guns
away and so it becomes very convenient
to say look at all these countries and
they got
by the way all this and I'm just not
engaging on it the US does have
certainly at least among the highest
rates of gun ownership and the
correlation that you see between the
number of guns and gun deaths is
definitely on the side of more guns
results in more gun deaths just like
more cars will result in more car deaths
or more hammers will result in in more
Hammer deaths but I don't engage on that
because the fact is the fact there are
you know 300 million plus guns out there
in America we are not taking those guns
away it is counterproductive to argue
taking you know take taking guns away
from anybody it's counterproductive
because it distracts from the real
things that we can do that the owners of
those 300 million guns would listen to
but aren't currently listening to
because they think you're trying to take
their their their guns away
okay have there been laws implemented to
restrict
I'm gonna make sure I get my my words
right but
um the guns that like that they're like
automatic you can shoot a whole bunch of
them yeah so they're not those have been
restricted right yeah those have been
restricted to machine guns fully
automatic guns have been restricted very
heavily for a long time
um the debate is over what are called
assault weapons
um and assault weapons like the AR-15
those are semi-automatic um and then
also as part of that large capacity uh
magazines where you can just so an
automatic gun is where you hold down the
trigger and it just fires a
semi-automatic is where you have to pull
the trigger each time individually and
they have large capacity magazines and
you know and that's that's what the uh
the the debate is is over
um and
believe it or not that's also a debate
that I think is not the right place to
put our emphasis for for a variety of
important reasons
um let's just start with
an important one but I don't think the
most important one which is it's
difficult to Define what an assault
weapon is and where you you know and
where you draw the line and people you
know do people use AR-15s for hunting
absolutely but what about target
shooting and is that you know so that
become and by the way my brother was
shot with a semi-automatic gun with a
high capacity magazine so I'm not just
cavalierly saying this yeah you know if
that person didn't have that gun there's
a good chance my brother
um you know wouldn't have been shot or
wouldn't have been as previous but I'm
just thinking about this in terms of how
to have the biggest impact so there's a
question in terms of how to define what
is in a soluble and that winds up being
you know uh a you know that's it
Tucker freaking Carlson you know I went
on his show and did an interview and all
he wanted to talk about is like can you
define an assault weapon I'm like I'm
not here to talk about that I'm here to
talk about keeping the guns out of the
hands we all of the people we all he had
no interest in talking about that
because that's not what his viewers want
to hear and that's not how he gets get
gets rating so you know so I I like to
first kind of put put that aside
um then looking at it
pragmatically and again I'm myself have
had personal experience with the very
unpragmatic side of this
um the percentage of gun deaths and
injuries even the percentage of mass
shootings even the percentage of school
shootings is
relatively low in the case of the mass
shootings and just tiny in terms of the
overall toll of gun deaths in our
country so the and and the word you know
assault weapon what you'll usually hear
is in the context of what the gun
control Community says and the gun
rights Community likes to
um pair it back assault weapons ban we
gotta ban these assault weapons problem
is it has the word ban in it it makes it
seem like we're coming for your guns it
gives people a ground to stand on that's
at least debatable in terms of the
Second Amendment it's my right to own
this gun well the second amendment can
be you're already in a place where
you've lost
kind of the emotional Resonance of the
argument instead and this is why I go
back to what I said in the beginning
let's talk not about how to keep
certain guns assault weapons in this
case from everybody from all people
let's talk about how to keep every gun
assault weapons and otherwise from the
people who are most likely and already
defined as most likely to harm and
already defined as the most dangerous
people so like a background check I
don't care whether it's an AR-15 or a
Saturday night special I care that a gun
trafficker convicted felon can't walk
into a you know a a gun show or go
online or meet somebody in a parking lot
and and buy it and and buy it and buy
that gun
okay you mentioned earlier and this is
something I wasn't familiar with straw
purchaser
yeah um so straw purchaser is somebody
who
um I'm not I'm not saying you ever did
this but
um when one is 15 years old and and they
need to get a beer in 7-Eleven
um they uh they say somebody in the
parking lot definitely done that by the
gun and then and then sell them the beer
give them the beer not no no no judgment
no accusation but that person was a
straw purchaser what happens with with
guns is
um people who can pass background checks
very often when they're not getting it
at places that don't require background
checks we'll go and buy you know dozens
of guns scores of guns sometimes in
another state and bring them back and
sell them
um in the communities that are most
impacted by gun bombs it goes back to
the question you say before well in New
York you know Chicago Illinois Chicago
is the toughest gun laws and why do they
have so much gun violence a big part of
that is because of these straw
purchasers they'll buy the guns they're
middle people they'll buy the guns
they'll the I think the technical term
would be like a straw man straw woman
whatever they are mostly men
um purchaser who will buy that gun and
then go and sell it and and make a
profit and they're just like ridiculous
examples of what happened so there's one
gun store right on the outskirts of
Chicago called uh but over the Chicago
City Limit so this person can exist
there called Chuck's Gun Shop and and
Pistol Range where that is known to sell
a high percentage of the guns that turn
up on the streets of Chicago
in the terrible toll of gun violence
that happens there you know seemingly on
on a daily basis and a big part of that
is because of these straw purchasers and
what Chucks is what I've always called
um a a bad apple gun dealer because
they're kind of spoiling it for everyone
else a tiny percentage of gun dealers
engage in that behavior where they are
knowingly selling guns like you know
sure I'll sell you these 20 guns and not
ask a question because you can pass this
background check knowingly selling guns
that are winding up on the streets and
causing uh all this gun violence so
another thing in addition to crop
cracking down on the straw purchasers is
also cracking down on these unscrupulous
uh these unscrupulous gun dealers who I
mean it's not it's like the 80 20 rule
on steroids like the 80 20 rule would be
20 of gun owners sell 80 of of crime
guns it's more like
five percent of gun dealers sell 95 of
crime guns so if we can just do
something to go after these gun dealers
and crack down on straw purchasers that
to me has always been one of the big
opportunities to affect gun violence in
these communities where and then so you
can start to see how somebody who says
well there's nothing we can do in
Chicago in terms of gun control so let's
not have this conversation because
Chicago already has tough gun laws I
just explain to you how yes Chicago is
very tough gun laws but shocks is not
covered the straw purchasers are not are
not are not being dealt with and that is
the reason why they have that gun
violence
okay that's interesting so do you have
suggestions on how these straw purchases
would be cracked down on yeah so one one
aspect of it we've already talked about
which is to make sure that everyone
has to who's engaged in the business
Commercial the business of selling guns
has to do background checks
so that so a straw purchaser can't walk
into you know a gun show
um can't go online and to to one of
these websites that I will not advertise
um and buy guns from strangers without a
background check and if we did that that
would have a very a very big impact and
I'll tell you the state fact that is
relevant is the states with the weakest
laws in that regard are the states that
are the sources of most of the crime
guns in New York and Chicago and Detroit
and the places that are
um you know in a lot of smaller places I
don't mean to just give the I love all
three of those cities
um you know but it's happening
everywhere and it's happening because
they call I-95 the firearm freeway
because the guns come up from the States
along the Eastern Seaboard that have
weak gun laws the southern states around
things like straw purchasers and
background checks and they're brought up
to you know Newark I'll pick on someone
else or you know
um other other places on the Eastern
Seaboard that might have tougher gun
laws so that's one thing that we can do
and then the other thing that we can do
is
all out war on these unscrupulous gun
dealers who are doing this knowingly
throw real resources at it because like
the numbers are there again five percent
of gun gun dealers sell 95 percent of
crime guns you know you wanna you you
wanna like really focus on something
bring the weight of the government down
on something you know uh we have to
leave no stone unturned in terms of
going after those gun dealers that are
literally knowingly supplying guns onto
the streets and by the way giving a bad
name to the 95 of gun dealers that sell
zero crime guns
okay so you could potentially identify
crime guns and then if a whole bunch of
them are coming from one place crack
down on that place and that's how you do
that and they have that info
they have that info yeah that info
exists that's weird yeah right
yeah that's that's why that that to me
has always been
the you know possibly the biggest thing
so what I get
not frustrated because there's a lot of
good conversation about things like you
know
changing the so you know the
socioeconomics and the
um systemic racism and
um you know the oppression of you know
people in these impacted communities
um and that's right that's a
conversation that has to be had
um and then there are great programs
like the violence Interrupters that go
in and you know when it seems like
there's a I don't want to like
marginalize myself by saying beef but or
at one point that was the like starting
or there's been one shooting to kind of
come in and intervene in somebody who
might be a former gang member and and
and kind of bring people together to
prevent it from escalating into more
these are very very important things I
look at look at it as tent pulse
um the Third Temple that does not get
discussed as prevalently as the other
two but I think as it relates to gun
violence not a whole host of other
things that are impacted by it by by
um all the by systemic racism and and
and and and other forms of Oppression
um you know it's the it it doesn't get
talked about and it would have on gun
violence just as much as an impact if
not more
um than than either of those two things
at least in the near time
yeah okay well I think I think that
summarizes your stance fairly well thank
you very much for coming on uh is there
anything else you want people to know or
any websites you want people to go to or
where people can find you before we end
this part of the segment yeah um they
can look me up at uh degross Pax on uh
on Twitter
um and uh yeah where the organization
that I'm starting with a guy in the gun
rights Community very prevalent uh
activist in the gun rights Community
it's called the center for gun rights
and responsibility so you can just uh
search that up and see the latest in
terms of what's going on there and I
want to thank you for first of all your
intention of bringing the bringing
people together and having a good
conversation and that is consistent with
certainly the way that I I look at look
at this issue and for doing your
research and being so prepared for this
conversation and for yeah for letting me
ramble and kind of get my get my points
across so thank you Michaela well thank
you that was very informative thanks
again for coming on cool you have a good
one
after John Lott welcome to my podcast
well thanks for having me on good to
talk to you
this should be a good conversation uh
before we get started could you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
hello my name is John Lott I'm president
of the crime prevention Research Center
I have a PhD in economics I've held uh
teaching and research professorships at
Stanford University of Chicago the
Wharton business school Yale I was Chief
Economist for the United States
sentencing commission uh and then more
recently I was senior advisor for
research and statistics for the U.S
department of justice so I've had both
academic positions and
positions in the federal government to
deal with law enforcement type issues
okay and then before I start hammering
you with questions what are your views
on gun control at the moment are there
things that could be improved too many
guns not enough guns can you give a
brief background about just how you see
gun control in America
well I think unfortunately a lot of the
gun control that we have right now
primarily disarms the very people who
need protection the most if my research
convinces Me of anything it's people who
are most likely victims of violent crime
overwhelmingly poor blacks who live in
high crime urban areas who are the ones
who benefit the most from having the
option to be able to go and protect
themselves the police are very important
but the police themselves understand
that they virtually always arrive on the
crime scene after the crimes committed
and having a gun turns out to be by far
the safest course of action
unfortunately
a lot of the gun control laws that we
have make it very costly for poor people
and discriminated against minorities so
just give you one example from when I
was just working in the federal
government and that is you know we hear
that the background check system has
stopped 3.8 million prohibited people
from be able to go and obtain a gun
that's simply false what they should say
is that there have been 3.8 million
initial denials and over 99 percent of
those are mistakes it's one thing to
stop a felon from buying a gun it's
another thing to stop somebody simply
because they've been named similar to a
felon from being able to go and buy a
gun and the problem is is that mistakes
overwhelmingly discriminate against
black males and Hispanic males the error
rate for black males is more than three
times their share of the population and
for Hispanic males it's more than two
and a half times their share of the
population and there's no reason why we
should have these mistakes occurring
private companies do background checks
on employees all the time if they had an
error rate that was 100th the error rate
that the federal government has they'd
be sued out of existence
and yet you know I think this is a very
reasonable fix why not make the federal
government have to meet the same
standards for doing background checks
that private companies have to make but
gun control Advocates will fight you
tooth and nail against that and there
are other issues too just look at the
costs
in in Washington DC where they're voting
on us they have background checks in the
private transfers of guns it costs 125
dollars to do a background check on on
each gun that you're going to sell let's
say you and I lived in Washington DC uh
and I'm going to go and give you four
guns it's just one person
giving one other person Four Guns you're
thinking just be one background check
because you're the same person who's
getting all the guns right but no they
have it set up so that there has to be a
separate background check done on each
gun and so the total cost of making that
one transfer is five hundred dollars
provide me with a logical explanation
for why they need to make it so
incredibly costly for people going by
guns it may not stop you or I from being
able to go and get a gun but again the
very people who need protection the most
are being priced out of this you know
Democrats will go and say you know we
can't have uh uh
voter IDs government issued photo IDs
for for voting because that imposes too
large of a burden on poor minorities
well how does a 125 dollar fee affect it
and that's not even the cost of getting
the ID you have to have a government
issued ID in order to go and buy a gun
and then they have other licensing rules
and other things that just make it very
costly uh give me one other example and
that is compare Illinois and Indiana
okay uh Illinois a heavily Democratic
State Indiana heavily Republican state
in Indiana over 20 percent of the adult
population has a concealed carry permit
in Illinois it's three percent and and
there's a simple reason for that in
Illinois it costs about 450 dollars to
go through the process to get a
concealed carry permit in Indiana it's
zero
you look at the distribution the only
types of people who go and get Concealed
Carry Permits in Illinois are
overwhelmingly white wealthy males who
live in the suburbs in Indiana uh it's
much more poor blacks and Hispanics who
live in high crime urban areas who have
been able to go and afford to go and
protect themselves and you go down the
list and in uh in Chicago up until very
recently they banned any training
facilities for getting a concealed carry
permit so you're a poor black there they
require 16 hours of trading you know if
you don't have a car you have to go and
borrow a car either two or four days
because it's a 16 hour training that's
there they don't allow you to take even
a permanent concealed handgun on public
transportation
so what does that do it makes it it's
like they went through the list 450
costs unable to take it on public
transportation uh no training facilities
allowed nearby you it's kind of like
they went down a checklist to do
everything they possibly can to make
sure that the very people who need
protection the most are the ones who are
not able to do it and I I'll give you
one last example
there's two types two main types of
concealed carry laws in the United
States they're what we call right to
carry laws which 42 of the states have
which once you meet certain criteria
you're allowed to carry you know you pay
a fee you pass a background check you do
your training
and then there are eight states like New
York and California where you have to
provide a good reason to some public
official why they should let you be able
to go and have an option to carry a
concealed handgun so take Los Angeles
County okay where I was able to get a
list of everybody who had gotten
approved for getting a concealed handgun
permit they only had like 216 Concealed
Carry Permits out of an adult population
of 8 million people but who do they give
who do they decide has a good reason
Nationwide about a third of concealed
carry permit holders are women in Los
Angeles County it's seven percent
Nationwide 13 of concealed carry permit
holders are black in Los Angeles County
it's 5 percent
54 of Los Angeles County's population is
Hispanic only six percent of the permit
holders are Hispanic you know you think
are women only stocked in the rest of
the country and not being stalked in Los
Angeles County don't they have good
reasons that are given there and yet the
public officials there
who are who are overwhelmingly 100
Democrat don't seem to the only people
that they think provide them with good
reasons to be able to carry are
basically wealthy politically connected
white males overwhelmingly are the ones
that they decide have good reasons why
is it
they say they care about poor and
minorities they say they care about
women but yet they don't seem to trust
those very same people when they're
asking for permission to be able to go
and defend themselves and their families
Okay so
how should the government regulate guns
like for these background checks how do
they decide who should have access to a
gun and who shouldn't
well I mean you can go and have it so
that people who have felony backgrounds
violent felony backgrounds in particular
can be stopped from me I'm going to go
and get guts I'm no problem with that my
point is simply if you're going to have
these make it so the system works have
reasonable fixes to the background check
system
you know otherwise you're you're you're
making it so that the very people who
need protection the most are being
priced out of being able to do it and
having mistakes look you can go and
appeal when the federal government makes
a mistake but virtually everybody's
going to require a lawyer to help them
go through the process fix the thing the
starting costs for hiring a lawyer is
like three thousand dollars on up
okay why should somebody through no
fault of their own simply because the
federal government's looking at roughly
phonetically similar names and similar
birthdays than doing background checks
why should they have to pay three
thousand dollars or more to fix a
mistake that's not their fault
so you're saying keep the background
checks but fix the inconsistencies
right but here's the problem and that
exactly but here's the problem I've been
making this argument for 20 years but
Democrats will fight you tooth and nail
against a simple fix I want somebody to
explain to me what reasonable
explanation can you give for why 99
percent
of the people who are stopped from
buying guns because of background checks
are mistakes
give me give me an explanation for why
you'd want a system where virtually
everybody who gets stopped is not the
guy you think you're stopping
seems reasonable
so how easy though for people who get
stopped with background checks how easy
is it for them to go to say a gun show
and then get a gun there
well I mean the vast majority of guns
anybody who's a licensed dealer who's
selling a gun any place has to go into a
background check I don't know if you've
ever been to a gun show but virtually
everybody who's selling a gun there is a
licensed dealer and they have to go
through and do a background check that's
there look we the federal government or
I've been has done surveys of criminals
to find out where they go and get their
guns you're talking about maybe less
than one percent maybe six tenths of one
percent of felons get their guns from
either gun shows or flea markets this is
not a major source of guns look if
you're where do you think the major
source of guns for for criminals are
it's drug deals drug dealers have guns
simply because they have to go and
protect their valuable property that
they have it's not like a drug dealer
can go to the police and say this other
dealer stole my drugs can you help us
get them back all right they have to go
and set up essentially their own little
militaries in order to go and protect
that valuable property that they have
so you know drug dealers like to make
money and if they can make money selling
drugs they do that if they can make
money selling guns they do that too and
you know uh it's
if you think you're going to be able to
stop criminals from buying guns any more
easily then you can stop them from
buying illegal drugs good luck with that
I mean I give talks at universities I go
and ask students you know if I give them
a few days how many of them can go and
buy different types of illegal drugs and
I'm not saying they do this but you have
maybe 80 percent of the students raise
their hands and think that there's no
problem that they're going to be able to
do it yeah
these drug dealers have very valuable
property you know you look at a country
like Mexico okay next door to us there
um Mexico since 1972 has had only one
gun store in the country
it's located in Mexico City it's run by
the military guns are extremely
expensive the most powerful gun that
you've been able to legally Buy in
Mexico since 1972 is a 22 caliber short
round rifle which is about the least
powerful gun that you can go and buy in
the United States and you know
um only only about one tenth of one
percent of Mexican adults is legally
licensed to own a gun it costs like two
thousand dollar fee just to go and apply
for the process to go and get a get a
gun to own in your home in Mexico uh you
can't sell it to anybody even if you do
get a gun the only people you can sell
it back to is the federal government
so you think boy they have incredibly
strict gun control laws and yet Mexico
has a murder rate six times higher than
the murder rate that we have in the
United States
drug dealers in Mexico bring in drugs
from around the rest of the world and
they go and bring in weapons from around
the world
when I was recently testifying a few
years ago in Mexico before the federal
Senate and House you know it's amazing
you go talk to law enforcement there
they had found something like 15
000 hand grenades that they had
confiscated from uh uh drug gangs down
there do you think you go to American uh
gun stores and buy hand grenades they
had confiscated machine guns do you
think you'd go to gun stores in the
United States and buy machine guns no
these are weapons some of them they
stole from the Mexican military but lots
of them they brought they brought in
from around the world South America and
Asia and other places like that and you
know they have rocket launchers they
have all sorts of other things because
there's a huge amount of money involved
in drug smoke that's there and so it
pays for them to go and buy weapons to
protect themselves not just from the
government but also from other drug
gangs that will try to steal their
valuable property that's there if I
could click my fingers
right now and cause all guns in the
United States to disappear and all
illegal drugs how long do you think it
would be before illegal drugs started
coming back into the United States
if you're in El Paso 20 minutes
and how long before they'd go and bring
in the illegal guns to go and protect
that valuable property they'd bring them
in at the same time they're not going to
risk bringing in huge amounts of very
valuable property that could be stolen
from them and they want to protect them
and so you know the notion that somehow
you know you're going to be any more
successful in stopping criminals from
getting guns than you've been from
stopping them from getting illegal drugs
I just don't think is very serious and
what people have to realize is what a
huge percentage of murders in the United
States are drug gang related
over half the murders in the United
States occur within two percent of the
counts that's 60 of the
3140 counties in the United States
account for over half the murders and if
you look at what's called a murder map
of those counties what you'll find is
almost two-thirds of their murders take
place within 10 block areas murders
unlike most other countries murders in
the United States are extremely heavily
concentrated in very tiny areas within
the United States you have you have
three quarters of the counties in the
United States that have either zero
murders for one murder in a year but
sixty percent have zero murders in any
given year
you know by the way those are the
counties that tend to have the highest
gun ownership rates in the United States
but
you know in any case uh if you're gonna
deal with the murder problem in the
United States you're gonna have to go
and deal with drugs and that's a
conversation I'm happy to have but uh I
just mentioned one other thing and that
is people have to realize that the vast
majority of violent crime in the United
States also doesn't involve guns 92
percent of violent crime in the United
States has no connection with guns in
any way so if you're going to go and
solve violent crime you have to go and
deal with violent crime General but if
you're going to deal with murders
you're going to have to go and deal with
drug tests because they fight against
each other all the time to try to
control drug terms
I've heard that and I could be wrong but
I've heard that a lot of the guns used
in crime in the states are bought
through straw purchases purchasers is
that true
look
one I don't believe that that's the case
you look at surveys of people who are in
prison that's not the case they buy them
off the street they buy them from others
that are there but here's the problem
and that is
they're close substitute ways for though
them to go and get guts you know just as
the discussion we were just having you
know if I could go and cause all guns to
disappear from the United States do you
think do you think Newt guns will be
brought in to protect the drug gangs
that are there
and if you think that definitely yeah
okay so if you think that that's the
case then you know even if you stop one
way even if that was a significant way
of doing it there are other ways that
they're going to go and get the weapons
that they need to protect their valuable
property
okay so you're suggesting well we keep
the background checks but that it has to
be fixed so that it's not randomly
choosing people with similar names to
people who've caused violent crimes
right similar names and similar
birthdays I mean I I don't know if
you've ever bought a gun but you fill
out something called a 4473 you put down
your name your address your social
security number your birthday your race
your eye color you think they're using
all that information but they're not
they're the vast majority of checks just
look at roughly phonetically similar
names and similar birthdays and there's
no reason why that should be the case
unfortunately I've come to the
conclusion that oh the people who are
pushing these background checks really
don't care about the background checks
because they could get them passed
tomorrow or today if they just made a
few really simple changes make it so
that uh the the federal government has
to meet the same standards for doing
background checks that private companies
do
pay for the checks out of General
Revenue so here here's the general point
if you believe that background checks
reduce violent crime then you believe it
reduces it for everybody not just the
person who's going out of the way to go
and obey the law that's there and also
you think you want to encourage people
to go and obey the law how does making
somebody have to pay 125 dollars to go
and do the background check encourage
them to go and do that because you're
essentially taxing them to go and do
what you want them to do yeah go out of
their way to do that so as an economist
I would say look if everybody benefits
everybody should pay and if you want to
encourage people to do this both reasons
tell me you should pay for it out of
General Revenue if you could make those
two changes fix the mistakes and make
and deal with paying for it out of
General Revenue if you think there are
these big benefits and I I'm skeptical
there are but if you think there are
these big benefits you'd think they'd
want to do that and yet and I've been
telling them for 20 years they could get
this passed right away but they refused
to make those changes and to me I have
to ask myself
what are the arguments against these
things the only arguments that I can
think of against these things is that
they want to make it costly they want to
make it difficult they want to prevent
poor minorities from being able to go
and buy guns if you have another
explanation in fact when we were setting
this up I was hoping that we could have
the gun control person on at the same
time so that they could say what their
explanation is for something like this
because I never hear an explanation when
I go and I bring up these concerns
yeah well those are fair questions
those are fair questions I may set these
up in the future so that I have both
people on at once but for now it's
interesting I'm not criticizing each
video I'm just saying I really want it's
very hard to get debates on these types
of things because gun control activists
refuse to appear on at the same time and
the main reason is is because they don't
have to most the media doesn't make them
have to go on debates
do you think that people pushing that
are just concerned with maybe kind of
punishing people who want to own guns
and saying okay you have to do these
fees and we're not footing it and
they're not even considering the fact
that some people have less money
I think I think that's right I think
they're trying to make it as costly as
possible for people to be able to go and
get guns I'll give you another related
example
and that is uh look at these red flag
laws that they have uh they're being
pushed in fact uh it looks like right
now the federal government's likely to
uh be using a lot of money to encourage
states to adopt these laws in the
current 3.5 trillion dollar spending
bill that they have what are the laws
well these These are laws uh that are
set up so that if you're concerned about
somebody being a danger to themselves or
others you can go and register a
complaint a judge will see a piece of
paper with the complaint and then
they'll go and take away the person's
gun that's there for some period of time
maybe a month and then there'll be a
hearing whether or not to make it
permanent or not yikes okay uh so here's
the deal
we already have in all the states and it
goes by different names often called
Baker Act California is called 5150
where if you're concerned somebody's a
danger to themselves or others you go to
the police the person will undergo a
24-hour to 72-hour psychiatric
evaluation where you'll have psychiatric
experts there and then you'll have
immediately following that a hearing
where if you can't afford it a lawyer
will be provided for you okay and the
judge has a whole range of options then
he can go and require that you get
voluntary treatment uh he can go and
take away your weapons if he's concerned
about that or he can go in the most
extreme case and involuntarily commit
somebody
virtually always all these things are
used for concerns about suicide that's
yes the thing is the red flag laws don't
involve Mental Health Care Experts okay
uh if you can't afford a lawyer tough
you know you have to you go in on your
own in fact you look at these cases in
the red flag law
uh it costs about ten thousand dollars
to go and do a hearing the only thing
that happens Under the Red Flag laws is
that you lose your ability to have a gun
well I may want to have a gun I may care
about it for protection but ten thousand
dollars I mean ten thousand dollars is a
lot of money there and so the vast
majority of people who go through that
process
uh don't get a lawyer when they have to
go to court uh and it makes it pretty
hard when you're up against lawyers and
you don't have a lawyer yourself
representing you uh to be able to go and
win those types of cases but it's it's
not because the people think that
they're really a danger or whatever it's
just that they don't even if they can't
afford it but here's the problem is that
the type of change that they want to
make can actually have the opposite
effect of what they'd like to have what
they claim they want to have happen I
have a very close friend of mine uh who
those
watched her husband be murdered in front
of her by one of her stalkers
and um
if you have these types of red flag
looks that are there let's say a friend
of hers a relative neighbor they say
look she's really depressed okay
I mean anybody would be you've just had
your loved one watched your loved one
murdered in front of you by one of your
stalkers that are there
and they know that she has a gun and so
they could go and say look I'm worried
she's depressed I'm going to she has a
gun I'll make a complaint the only thing
the judge sees when he makes the
decision whether or not to take away the
person's gun is that written complaint
well in her case
if you put yourself in that situation
you've just had one of your stalkers
murdered your husband
how do you think you'd feel if your
ability to go and protect yourself was
going to be taken away from do you think
that'd make you even more depressed and
what does that do to your incentive to
go and talk to people to share your
feelings with others if you worry that
somebody might misinterpret it
simply being able to go and talk to
people it's very helpful when you're
incredible extremely depressed like that
just being able to share your feelings
know that you're not alone can make a
huge difference in terms of how people
get through this type of thing and yet
the gun control Advocates have set up a
process in uh 18 states now where
simply could be a very well-meaning
person puts in a complaint judge hears
nothing from the person who's the
complaint is being lodged against and
you know he may be well-meaning himself
he sees this person's depressed they
have a gun yeah
but if you have the process that we've
had these Baker Act type things she
could go in there she gets evaluated by
a psychiatric expert she can explain to
the expert why it's important that she
still be able to go and defend herself
and even if she couldn't convince that
person she goes to court and if she
can't afford a lawyer one is provided
for her and she can make an argument to
the judge so you have to ask yourself
why did gun control Advocates push a
situation where it would make people
actually afraid to go and talk to people
you take police officers police officers
tend to commit suicide at a relatively
High rate compared to the general
population they tend to be depressed in
a relatively High rate compared to the
rest of the population
why I mean they see horrible things on
the job all the time do we want to make
it so police officers are afraid to go
and share their feelings with other
people if you take away a police
officer's gun what do you think you do
to their job
you've taken away their job that's there
they lose their job if you take away
their guts
do we want to make it so the police
officers are afraid to go and talk to
people and yet again I think these are
simple reasonable changes okay
pay for a lawyer if a person can't
afford it make that include Mental
Health Care Experts into process and
have mental health care experts evaluate
the person before you go and you have a
hearing don't have the the judge simply
making a decision based only on seeing
the written complaint and not being able
to hear the other person's side of the
story when he's making that type of
decision that's there
you know and besides if I'm really
concerned about somebody committing
suicide really concern is the only
solution to take away their gun is there
like no other way for these people to go
and kill themselves I mean go talk to
Jeffrey Epstein if you don't think that
there's other ways for people to go in
and kill themselves uh and so
you know it's I think a lot of this is
just to demonize the gun it's just to
say well if you take away the guns
Situation's solved there's no problem at
that point and I think that's really
dangerous I think that's really
misleading for people and I think
there's evidence out there that in fact
you increase suicide rates and I think
for the reason that I was just
mentioning that you make it so that
people now are afraid to go and share
their feelings and talk to other people
what do you think of people who think
that there needs to be more education
surrounding how you store guns and
safety with guns and that that's one of
the problems with American gun control
at the moment is just lack of Education
I have no problem with people being
educated about it but here's the thing I
think if you look at the numbers
Americans are extremely responsible with
regard to guns uh you can go to the
Centers for Disease Control website uh
their uh fatal injury report data that
they have and what you'll find for let's
say kids under age 10 in the United
States for the most recent year there
was 36 accidental gun deaths in the
United States there's 36 do you wish it
was Zero yeah sure I wish it was Zero
but when you consider half of American
homes have guns okay
um and you go and you look at anything
else when you have like 95 kids under
five who grounded in uh in five gallon
water buckets
you have uh more than that who drowned
in bathtubs in the homes
so if I were to go and just ask you
beforehand and say okay
guns are owned in half of American homes
what is your guess that children under
age 10 died from accidental gunshots my
guess is your number would have been
much higher than Thursday yeah yeah and
part of the reason is is whenever these
things happen they get national news
coverage and it makes people think that
they're more common than they are I
think to some extent but
you know uh and even when you look at
those 36 uh about two-thirds of those
are not Shots by other children they're
Shots by adult males usually in their
mid to late 20s who have criminal
records who have in many cases it's
illegal for them to own guns and are
often drug addicts or alcoholics so you
know I can go and say we want to educate
people but a lot of these guys it's
illegal for them to own the gun to begin
with and so if I go and pass a gun lock
law is it going to affect these guys and
a gun Lock's not going to affect an
adult male particularly an adult male
criminal who's unlikely to go and obey
the law to begin with to be able to go
uh and do it it's not going to stop him
from the accidentally firing his gun
but here's the problem and that is
their costs and benefits I I mean as an
economist we're always weighing
trade-offs with different things and so
I go and pass a law that requires people
have to lock up their guns in their
homes okay which is one of the things
that's involved with this
it doesn't make sense for everybody to
do it if I live in a high crime urban
area I may want to have quick access to
a gun that's there delaying it may make
it so that I'm not able to and defend
myself and my family you have to weigh
the risks of the gun in the home versus
the fact that people aren't going to be
able to go and defend themselves and
often when these laws get passed you'll
see about a five percentage Point drop
in gun ownership that occurs right when
these safe storage laws get passed and a
lot of that has to do with the
exaggerated stories that occur in the
media at that time about the dangers of
having guns in the home and so look I
mean I have five kids I don't want
anything to happen to any of my kids but
I would go and argue that the vast
majority of Americans are extremely
careful look the risk of a child dying
from an accidental gunshot in the home
is less than the rest of them dying from
light nothing strikes did I go and tell
my kids not to go in an open field with
an umbrella when it's lightning outside
yeah sure there's sensible things you
try to go and do I would just argue I
think looking at the data that the vast
majority of Americans are actually
behaving fairly responsibly and that
unfortunately this gets back to your
point before about whether it's a lot of
these laws are just trying to make it
cost for people to be able to go and own
guns and I think this is just another
example of it they try in many different
ways to do that
okay last question do do states that
have stricter gun laws does that reduce
gun crime
no it has the opposite effect
let me give you just a simple example
just to think about this is an extreme
case but it applies generally and that
is can you name me one place in the
world that's banned either all guns or
all handguns and seen murder or homicide
rates go down just one place I'm talking
about before and after because there's
all sorts of reasons why different
places differ uh in terms of crime rates
uh yeah I can't find a single place
every single time
murder rates go up you think out of
Randomness once or twice it would go now
uh you'd think particularly if you
believe guns on net are bad you would
think for sure it should go down every
single time and yet every single time
you know Americans know about what
happened in Chicago
in Washington DC when we had handgun
bans there and the murder rates went up
gun control Advocates although will say
well that really wasn't a fair test
because unless you go and you ban guns
every place uh people can still go and
get guns from Maryland or Virginia or
from the rest of Illinois or from
Indiana the problem is that doesn't
explain why the murder rates went up it
may explain why it didn't fall as much
as they were originally predicting it
was going to do but they were able to
get the guns from those other places to
begin with before the ban went into
effect and so but here's the problem and
that is and this applies to gun control
laws generally and that is you have to
be careful when you pass a law that
you're not going to be primarily
disarming law-abiding citizens relative
to criminals you may take some guns away
from criminals but if it's mainly in
this case law abiding citizens turning
in their guns obeying the laws so you're
primarily disarming the victims relative
to the criminals you actually can make
it easier for criminals to go and commit
crimes and so you see increases and so
when this applies to any of these things
the background check discussion that we
were having if it primarily because of
these mistakes and these costs and other
things primarily disarms law-abiding
citizens relative to criminals you can
actually have the opposite effect of
what you'd like to have happen in these
cases and so you know um
you know I I think if you look at the
serious statistical work I've been an
academic I've published over 120
peer-reviewed articles and journals uh I
think if you look at the serious work to
answer your specific question you find
that the states that have stricter gun
control laws tend to have uh higher
murder rates higher violent crime rates
and you know it's not just that you look
at concealed carry laws there's a huge
difference in across States in terms of
the percentage of the adult population
with concealed handgun permits uh uh
there as I mentioned there's basically
these two types of States these right to
carry states and these uh May issue
states in the May issue States you're
talking about literally a just a couple
few percentage points tenths of a
percentage point of the adult population
with a permit on average for the rest of
the states you're talking about nine
percent or so of the adult population
with permits uh and that was last year
my guess is it's probably about 10 right
now and so
you know uh and
anyway but what you find is that those
states that make it easier for people to
go and get concealed handgun permits
particularly those states that make it
easiest for poor and minority people the
people who are most likely victims of
violent crimes to be able to go and
defend themselves they have the the
biggest drops in violent crimes as more
permits are issued you see greater drops
in violent crime there's a reason why
police strongly support concealed carry
laws you look at surveys of police
officers you'll find like 95 percent of
police in a survey by police one which
is about 450 000 members 380 000 of them
are full-time law enforcement the other
seventy thousand are retired support
relatively easy access to concealed
handgun permits for people
uh you know they see the importance in
their own lives of of being able to go
and use a gun and they're strongly
supportive of private citizens being
able to do it uh you know you look at
another survey from them where they
asked them how important is it for
reducing crime for law-abiding citizens
to have guns
76 of police officers think that private
ownership of Guns is either extremely
important or very important in terms of
reducing crime
okay it's a lot
so you know these are the people that
have to deal with these situations all
the time and they
so okay wow I think that that settles it
for me I think I'm good I've asked you
the questions I wanted to ask you and
thank you very much for coming on if you
want to direct people to either follow
you online or attendee websites they
should know about where do they go
well our our website is
crimereesearch.org crime research.org
we're basically a group of academics as
I mentioned I've had positions in a
number of universities but we have
Arthur Berg at Harvard uh Bill Landis at
the University of Chicago uh Scott
Armstrong at the Wharton business school
others who have expertise in different
areas uh you know we know where the data
is and that's what we try to put out
regularly there so and people if they go
to crimereesearch.org they can sign up
for our email list uh once every two
weeks we send out an email so that
people can see the latest research that
we've been doing on these different
topics
very cool okay well thank you very much
for coming on
I appreciate your time thank you
[Music]